Boba Fett is one of the most iconic
characters in the Star Wars universe.
He might be just one man, but he's
been played by over a dozen actors
since the character was first created.
Think you can you name them all?
Before the release of The Empire Strikes Back or
even the infamous Holiday Special, Boba Fett made
his debut at an annual fall parade in San Anselmo,
California, on Sunday, September 24th, 1978.
San Anselmo was home to 52 Park Way, often
known as George Lucas' "secret lair" — which
is why it was chosen as the site of the beloved
bounty hunter's premiere. Assistant film editor
Duwayne Dunham wore the famous armor in the
parade simply because he was the right size.
"Sure, have him turn around and get a shot
at the jetpack. Can you do it, Duwayne?"
According to Dunham, the parade took place on
an extremely hot day in San Anselmo, which he
recalled "could have been 100 degrees." Since
no one knew who his character was at the time,
few fans approached him, though Dunham
did, in fact, sign autographs. For this,
he even had to ask a nearby producer, Gary
Kurtz, if "Fett" had one T in it, or two.
The first onscreen appearance of Boba Fett
came two months after the San Anselmo parade,
during the now-notorious Star Wars
Holiday Special. The bounty hunter
shows up in an animated sequence, in
which he is voiced by Don Francks.
"I take it you have no love of the Empire."
After the Millennium Falcon crashes on a water
planet, Luke and the droids try to rescue their
friends. As soon as they land, however, they're
threatened by a large beast that Fett fights off,
thus gaining the heroes' trust. In
truth, he's been sent by the Empire
to infiltrate the rebels in the hopes
of finding the location of their base.
Francks was a Canadian actor who worked
regularly up until his passing in 2016,
at the age of 84. His most visible roles
include Walter on the Canadian TV series
La Femme Nikita and Chief Jake Newby in the
1981 slasher classic My Bloody Valentine.
Most fans didn't get to meet Boba Fett until
he went on the hunt for Han Solo in The
Empire Strikes Back. For most of Boba Fett's
scenes in that movie and Return of the Jedi,
the man in the suit is Jeremy
Bulloch. The English actor had
appeared in multiple British TV series and
films before becoming part of Star Wars,
but his silent role as Boba Fett
remains by far his most well-remembered.
Speaking to io9 in 2011, Bulloch said he never
expected Boba Fett's character to become so
popular. When asked what he thought Boba got
up to after plunging into the sarlacc pit,
Bulloch suggested that Boba might have
tracked down and killed Mace Windu,
who killed Boba's father in Attack of the
Clones before appearing to die one movie later.
Bulloch continued to act on-and-off
in the decades after Empire,
and even made a cameo appearance in
Revenge of the Sith. In December 2020,
he died at the age of 75 from
complications of Parkinson's disease.
Jeremy Bulloch's face only appears once
during The Empire Strikes Back — and it
isn't while he's playing Boba. When Luke
Skywalker infiltrates Bespin's Cloud City,
Leia spots him and warns that he's falling into
a trap. At the same time, an Imperial officer
is trying to pull her away. That officer is
Lieutenant Sheckil, played by Bulloch. The
production's shooting schedules conflicted at the
time, however, and in order to shoot that scene,
Bulloch couldn't play Boba Fett in another
— one in which the bounty hunter walks down
a hallway with Vader, Lando, and Lobot. So John
Morton got to be Boba Fett for that one scene.
That isn't Morton's only role in Empire,
either. He also played rebel pilot Dak Ralter,
Luke Skywalker's gunner during the Battle of
Hoth. Having previously worked as a stuntman,
Morton didn't do much more acting during his
career, although he did score smaller roles
in two other sci-fi classics released the same
year as Empire — Flash Gordon and Superman II.
While Jeremy Bulloch and John Morton played the
physical role of Boba Fett in
the original Star Wars trilogy,
the voice fans initially heard coming out
of Fett's helmet was that of Jason Wingreen.
"What if he doesn't survive?
He's worth a lot to me."
This isn't the case for many
modern Star Wars fans, however,
as the 2004 DVD releases swapped
Wingreen's voice with Temuera Morrison's.
"What if he doesn't survive?
He's worth a lot to me."
Wingreen claimed that, for him, portraying Boba
Fett took "no more than 10 minutes" of work.
There's an argument to be made that
Wingreen wasn't treated very fairly
by the Star Wars franchise after lending
his voice to the famous bounty hunter. His
name wasn't included in the
credits of Empire Strikes Back,
and his involvement wasn't even public knowledge
until around the year 2000. Most shockingly,
he never received any residual compensation
for his work, even though his voice was used
for Boba Fett action figures. Wingreen died
on Christmas Day, 2015. He was 95 years old.
Back in 1981, George Lucas sold the radio
rights for the original Star Wars trilogy to NPR
for the whopping sum of $1; the filmmaker had been
listening to NPR since his college days, and was
inclined to feel generous towards them. All three
movies were eventually adapted into radio dramas,
split into half-hour-long installments. Certain
actors from the movies reprised their roles,
but most of the other characters had
to be recast — including Boba Fett.
In the 1983 Empire Strikes Back radio play,
Boba Fett was played by Alan Rosenberg, an actor
who has worked steadily since the late 1970s,
mostly in television. Unfortunately, by the time
a Return of the Jedi adaptation could be made,
federal funding cuts and a number of other factors
had put the radio play on hold. It wasn't until
1996 that the six-part drama was recorded, with
Ed Begley Jr. taking over the role of Boba Fett.
Around the same time, in 1994, the popular Dark
Empire comic book series was adapted into two
audio dramas. For the role of Boba Fett,
character actor Joseph Hacker was chosen.
Hacker has appeared on dozens of TV shows
over the years, from Quantum Leap to 24.
The final actor to play Fett in an audio drama was
the otherwise-unknown Tim Glovatsky, who played
the bounty hunter in Dark Forces: Rebel Agent,
an adaptation of the novel of the same name.
When the Special Edition of A
New Hope hit theaters in 1997,
it included an uncompleted scene from the
original production, in which Jabba the
Hutt and Han Solo talk before the Falcon leaves
Tatooine. Along with a group of armed henchmen,
Jabba is accompanied by the silent
but intimidating figure of Boba Fett.
The bounty hunter was worked into the
story digitally, courtesy of Industrial
Light and Magic animator Mark Austin, who
donned the iconic armor for the scene.
While his appearance is brief in A New Hope,
Austin obviously feels attached to the role.
He even played the bounty hunter for a second
time on the Boba Fett Fan Club's web series No
Disintegrations. These episodes are meant
to be transmissions from Boba Fett's ship,
most of which take place within
specific chapters of the saga.
When it came time to produce the
Special Edition of Return of the Jedi,
George Lucas apparently wanted more Boba
Fett — even though he never did manage to
work in an escape from the sarlacc pit. What
fans do get, however, is more time with the
armored bounty hunter during the extended song
and dance number in Jabba the Hutt's palace.
For most of these new Boba Fett
shots, special effects artist
Don Bies stepped into the character's iconic
armor. Nelson Hall, another VFX artist,
provided the rest of the footage for Fett.
In a 2016 interview with StarWars.com,
Bies revealed he also played a musician in
Jabba's band, as well as a whole bunch of
stormtroopers and Imperial officers in A New Hope.
Apparently, he and Nelson Hall stuck themselves in
so many scenes that their effects supervisor
actually had to ask them to tone it down.
If you're a fan of animated Star Wars
properties, you've likely heard Tom Kane's voice.
He's the narrator of Star Wars: The Clone
Wars, as well as the voice of Yoda in that
series and a number of other productions.
As far as Boba Fett is concerned, however,
Kane has portrayed the bounty hunter three
times — albeit only in Star Wars video games.
Kane's first outing as Boba Fett came
during 2000's Star Wars: Demolition,
a game in which players pit different vehicles
from the franchise against each other.
Kane voiced Fett once again in the 2001 real-time
strategy game Star Wars: Galactic Battlegrounds.
Finally, he played Fett in 2003's
Star Wars Jedi Knight: Jedi Academy,
which has a particularly special
place in many fans' hearts.
"Boba Fett!"
"This doesn't concern you, Jedi. Just walk away."
Attack of the Clones reveals a whole lot
about Boba Fett. First, it's shown that the
bounty hunter is a clone created as payment
to Jango Fett by the clone makers of Kamino,
in exchange for the use of his DNA to
create their clone army. The movie also
makes clear that Boba Fett's appreciation
of violence emerged at a young age. Finally,
it's revealed that Fett saw his father die on
Geonosis at Mace Windu's hands. The image of
young Boba Fett holding Jango's helmet is one
of the most memorable of the prequel trilogy.
Young Boba Fett is played by the New Zealand-born
actor Daniel Logan. Playing Boba left an
interesting mark on the young performer, too
— when Looper spoke to him in April 2020, he
revealed that, like Jake Lloyd, he suffered plenty
of bullying for his role in the trilogy. He said:
"I think we're very, very blessed that we came
in during the era right before social media
and this whole entire internet explosion,
because I think it could've turned out worse."
Luckily, this hasn't stopped him
embracing his connection with the
Star Wars saga — and when Logan got the
call to reprise his role on The Clone Wars,
he pretty much jumped at the opportunity.
In 1998, LucasArts and Nintendo teamed up
to release the flight action game Star Wars:
Rogue Squadron. In this game, the
player guides the eponymous rebel
group through a variety of mission objectives.
It proved popular enough to spawn two sequels,
including 2003's Star Wars:
Rogue Squadron III: Rebel Strike.
Actor Chris Cox played multiple
characters in Rebel Strike,
including Boba Fett. His Fett performance is
spotlighted by a mission that recreates Leia's
futile pursuit of the bounty hunter when
he leaves Bespin with the frozen Han Solo.
While Rebel Strike is the only game
in which Cox portrayed Boba Fett,
it's only one of many Star Wars games he's
worked on. The prolific voice actor can be
heard across the Star Wars galaxy, from Fallen
Order to Battlefront to The Force Unleashed.
While fans in his home country of New
Zealand were already familiar with
his work before he stepped into the Star
Wars universe, it was Temuera Morrison's
pitch-perfect performance as Jango Fett in
Attack of the Clones that made him known to
audiences around the world. Since that film
establishes that Boba is a clone of Jango,
it also laid the foundation for Morrison
to soften the disappointment so many
fans suffered in Return of the Jedi by finally
returning Boba Fett to the land of the living.
"Oh yeah, we got the Mandalorian
blues, on the sands of Tatooine."
Morrison voiced Boba Fett a number of times before
he played him in a live-action capacity, though.
When the Special Editions of the original trilogy
got new home releases in 2004, Jason Wingreen's
voice was replaced with Morrison's. Morrison
went on to voice the character in a number
of video games, including 2005's Battlefront II
and 2006's Empire at War. More recently, in the
second season of The Mandalorian, Morrison's
Boba Fett joins up with Din Djarin to help
rescue Grogu from the clutches of Moff Gideon.
Try saying that six times…. That season ended
with the revelation that Fett will be getting
his own solo series on Disney+ in December 2021.
Dee Bradley Baker has enjoyed a long, varied,
and incredibly successful voice acting career,
including a whole lot of work in
the Star Wars universe. He's perhaps
best known for voicing Captain Rex in The
Clone Wars, Rebels, and The Bad Batch,
though he also played a number of
clone troopers in each series..
Baker portrayed Boba Fett in both
of the Force Unleashed games, too.
In 2011, the year after Force
Unleashed II was released,
fans were able to hear him voice the bounty hunter
once again, albeit as part of a very different
production. That year, Disney's Hollywood Studios
debuted Star Tours — The Adventures Continue,
an attraction that sees Baker reprise his role
as the galaxy's most dangerous bounty hunter.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Boba Fett
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.